my whole mission in congress is about
the children for the children i have to
be prepared to throw a punch for the
children if you work hard
you can do better and pass on even
greater opportunities for your children
to decide our country's future
to determine your future the future of
your children
well today's liberals claim that
everything they're doing on climate
change covid the border even ending the
filibuster is because they care about
the children
but the real truth is very dark and very
sinister the left's core issues abortion
gender fluidity the diversity obsession
open borders and coveted mandates just
to name a few
actually add up to a war on children
from the more than 62 million babies
lost to abortion since 1973's roe versus
wade to the current fad of glamorizing
transgenderism in our schools we're
witnessing a sustained assault on life
and innocence by adults who themselves
are spiritually lost
over time it's become kind of
fashionable to see children as
burdensome inconvenient even sometimes
harmful to the environment
school-aged children who are coaxed into
early left-wing activism they're
celebrated and rewarded but those who
sit on the sidelines those who resist
the indoctrination on race or gender
victimology they're sidelined or
silenced
too many school boards and activist
teachers are trying right now to turn
our children into race obsessed america
hating whiners great stuff going on with
our social studies curriculum and um but
we if we want to talk about all the
other things and the components that
really will create an anti-racist school
system we have to look at it
systemically let's put it all out there
and let's really uproot systemic racism
anti-racism work has to begin by holding
up a mirror and taking a hard look at
your own biases
uh the mirrors would be reflecting a
sickening sight
a bunch of venal virtue-signaling
know-nothing bureaucrats
the same overpaid officials who care so
much about our kids that they're fine to
see them shivering outside in frigid
temperatures eating their lunches for
the lie of social distancing
these photos are infuriating
now i'm going to say this until i no
longer have breath in my body what blue
state politicians did to our kids and
canceling in-person school some of it's
still struggling canceling sports and
time on playgrounds what they're still
doing with mask and vax mandates is a
crime against humanity
but of course the dimwits in the media
oh they go right along
obviously the can 95 and 95 are the most
effective but it can be really hard to
find them in small kid sizes you really
want to make sure you have one that fits
your child's face
and you want to layer the cloth mask
over that mask so the surgical mask goes
on first and then the cloth mask listen
you hear that
grunting along well anthony fauci and
the public health robots that he's
inspired
see children as potential viral vectors
certainly not innocent little children
with robust immune systems
we know that six million kids have had
covet they can get it they can spread it
a lot of parents worry about sending
their kids to school well i mean that's
how a lot of what the kids pick up
adults get it right the kids bring it
home kids are drivers of spread
unvaccinated kids back at school are
driving community spread of covid
what horrible people at many top
colleges and universities your kids are
forced to submit to the covet vaccine
even if they've gotten coveted in the
past or they'll lose their education
look at how the university of chicago of
all places is harassing that unvaxxed
football player arthur long that we
featured last night on the show
and even more galling
the push online and in colleges now and
i thought i'd heard everything to
destigmatize pedophilia
by calling it something else question
i use the term minor attracted person or
math in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons it's less
stigmatizing than other terms like
pedophile using a term that communicates
who someone is attracted to
it doesn't indicate anything about the
morality of that attraction
minor attracted persons map
now you'll be relieved to know that that
individual has been suspended what
suspect suspended imagine if he'd simply
reiterated the concerns about voter
fraud that led to some of the people
showing up on january 6 he'd have been
fired on the spot for those comments
this is so twisted
now of course all of this is viciously
anti-child
but part of a larger mindset that's been
cultivated for decades now
now it's no secret that our culture has
a selfishness problem we all can be
selfish no doubt
and hedonism didn't begin in the 60s but
it certainly
you know ended up getting a big boost
with the free love generation remember
it was all sex without consequences that
was one of the biggest lies ever told
especially to women
god was kicked to the curb in the
schools and the religiously minded
became increasingly caricatured in film
now when i was a kid there were a lot of
families that had a lot of kids
and we all kind of figured it out we
helped each other out we were neighbors
but at some point big families were
suddenly considered weird and selfish
fringe
but of course the opposite is true
children require sacrifice children are
love
and as mother teresa said they're our
most precious treasures
before i adopted my three kids i focused
way too much on myself frankly i'm not
that interesting it wasn't good
sadly there are many who believe that
children are just potential problems
scientific consensus
that the lives of children are going to
be very difficult and it does lead i
think young people to
have a legitimate question you know
should
is it okay to still have children
struggle's bad by the way struggle is
never good
by the way they're even taking pledges
about this
you're getting people to sign a pledge
basically saying that they will not have
children until the canadian government
takes serious action on climate change
i don't really have a lot of hope for
the future and so
that
feeling of fear is where the pledge came
from
these depressing comments they're just
the byproducts of a radical and failing
education system and also failure of
parenting
but there's some prominent pushback
it's completely the opposite please look
at the numbers
if people don't have more children
civilization is going to crumble
mark my words
mark his words indeed and there are
plenty of other reasons for optimism out
there we've seen it at school board
meetings across the country where
parents are refusing to allow their
children to be pandemic lab rats for
indoctrination and experimentation
and we also see hope in the faces of the
thousands of young people including my
two sons who gathered today in
washington for the annual march for life
it's not necessarily convenient or even
fun to march in freezing dreary
washington every year
but it is a powerful statement for the
rights of the unborn
and it's a statement to a world that
seems so comfortable with the act of
discarding the children
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else